hey this is presh to Walker
you have an equilateral triangle ABC
construct its in circle and let P be any
point on its in circle
construct AP BP and CP
the challenge is to prove AP squared
plus BP squared plus CP squared is equal
to some constant k
so even as p goes around any point on
the in circle
the sum of the square distances from the
vertices of the triangle to the point p
is always a constant value
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
this is a challenging question and I did
not work it out myself but when I saw
the solution it was so amazing that I
just had to share it
so the technique to solve this
two-dimensional problem is to think in
three dimensions
so let's set up a coordinate system with
three axes X Y and Z and put the three
points a b and c on the three different
axes
foreign
the first thing we'll do is we'll set
convenient coordinates
Now ABC is an equilateral triangle so we
need the length of a b to be the length
of BC to be the length of AC
so here's one way that we can do that
let a be the point 1 0 0 B Be 0 1 0 and
C be 0 0 1. it's easy to calculate that
the length of a b is equal to the length
of BC is equal to the length of AC which
is equal to the square root of 2.
so this is an equilateral triangle we've
put in a coordinate system
now what is the equation of the plane
that passes through the points a b and c
this is also easy to figure out this is
the equation X Plus y plus Z is equal to
one it's easy enough to check that the
points a b and c will satisfy this
equation
now here comes the next amazing trick
what can we do about this in circle
so we will construct a sphere that
intersects with this plane and the
intersection of the sphere with the
plane will exactly be this in circle
now a general equation for a sphere
centered at the origin is x squared plus
y squared plus Z squared is equal to r
squared for R being the radius
in fact we can solve for the value of r
consider the midpoint of a b
this will be a point on the triangle and
it will also be a point on the in circle
so it's the point on the sphere
so what is the value of the midpoint it
will exactly be the average of the
coordinates of A and B so that will be
0.5.50
since this is a point on the sphere we
can substitute it into the equation x
squared plus y squared plus Z squared is
equal to r squared
so X is equal to 0.5 Y is equal to 0.5
and Z is equal to zero so we get 0.5
squared plus 0.5 squared plus 0 squared
is equal to r squared and this
simplifies to be r squared is equal to
0.5 so the equation of the sphere is x
squared plus y squared plus Z squared is
equal to 0.5
so where do we go from here we have the
equation of the plane with the equation
of the sphere and we have the
coordinates of a b and c
well our objective is to calculate AP
squared plus BP squared plus CP squared
so let's let the point P have
coordinates x y and z
so p is X Y and Z we know that a is one
zero zero so let's calculate the square
of the length of AP
so this will be the square of the
difference in the x coordinates plus the
square of the difference in the Y
coordinates plus the square of the
difference in the Z coordinates it'll be
the square of x minus 1 plus y squared
plus Z squared
now similarly let's calculate BP squared
B is 0 1 0
so BP squared will be equal to x squared
plus the square of Y minus 1 plus Z
squared
next let's go to CP squared C is the
point zero zero one so CP squared will
be x squared plus y squared plus the
square of Z minus 1.
now we want the sum of these so let's
sum these up
so we'll first expand each binomial
we have the square of x minus 1 in the
first equation the square of Y minus 1
in the second and the square of Z minus
1 in the third
so now we want to add up all these three
equations and it'll look very
complicated but don't worry this is all
going to simplify
so in the three equations we have three
x squared
we also have 3y squared and we also have
three Z squared
so we can write this as 3 times the sum
of x squared plus y squared plus Z
squared
now we also have negative 2x plus a
negative 2y plus negative 2z so this
would be minus 2 times the quantity X
Plus y plus Z
finally we have one plus one plus one
and that is equal to 3.
so let's focus on the sum of the square
distances
now we can do something magical we have
x squared plus y squared plus Z squared
but we know from the equation of the
sphere that this is equal to 0.5
here we have X Plus y plus Z and we know
from the equation of the plane that this
is equal to one since the point p is on
the sphere and the plane we can
substitute in these values so we
substitute in we get 3 times 0.5 minus
two times one plus three and that is
equal to 2.5
so we figured out that the sum of these
Square distance is always equal to some
constant for any point p
so in general when we have different
coordinates we have a p squared plus BP
squared plus CP squared is always equal
to some constant K and that completes
the proof
so now what is the value of K
so let's go back to our problem
so we know that the sum of the squared
distances is equal to K
so what we can do is pick a convenient
Point p
let's suppose that the equilateral
triangle has a b equal to AC equal to BC
equal to some side length s
so here's the convenient point we'll
pick we'll let P be the midpoint of a b
so then we have AP BP and CP as follows
AP will be S over 2 BP will be S over 2
and CP will be the altitude which is s
root 3 over 2 because APC is a 30 60 90
right triangle
so we now compute AP squared plus BP
squared plus CP squared this is easy
enough to do it's the square of s over 2
plus the square of s over 2 plus the
square of s root 3 all over 2. and this
works out to be S squared over 4 plus s
squared over 4 plus 3s squared over 4
which is equal to 5S squared over 4.
so we figured out the sum of the square
distances as 5S squared over four
amazing
what an interesting problem that we
solved a two-dimensional problem using
three-dimensional coordinates
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time